I know you talked about in your book on
writing and it was a chapter 12 group
therapy for writers would you say is
getting the most out of writing
conferences and writers groups just as
there's different you know some actors
are great in certain classes and
sometimes it's not a fit how does
someone know if it's a fit in terms of
the writing group how do we know that
you know what this is the writing group
for me or maybe nice people but I need
to move on I don't know if this is
really the fit for me I think it depends
on where you're at certainly if you've
written a couple of books a couple of
short short stories or something and
you've you know if you have some
material behind you already whether or
not it's published or not but you've
you've written a body of work you have
things to show I think it's it's you may
not want to be in a ranked beginning one
a ranked beginning group you may want to
find a group that's already you know
where everybody has at least they're
almost finished with their first one or
they actually have had something
published or they have a couple of short
stories that they've done or something
in other words it's not just starting
off at the very beginning I haven't
written anything yet and this is a
beginning writers group you want to try
and find one that's at the same level
that you are at the same time for people
who just finished writing their first
thing or just about ready to you know
try and get their work out there finding
a writers group that's in their same
genre is also very helpful mystery
writers
have a lot of groups children's books
they have a lot of groups in fact I'm
I'm gonna be doing a workshop for our
children's book writers in a couple of
days they're you know finding it in the
genre that you're in is important
because not it's not just general book
writing yeah we're just going to do this
and you know because if it's if you're
writing in mysteries or romance novels
you know historical dramas those kind of
books if you're in a particular genre of
a book it's best to be in a group that
also has the same type of
focus it because certain agents look for
certain only certain kinds of genres in
writing so you know this is what's
helpful is that you know again they have
regular writing conferences to South
Carolina Writers Pacific Northwest
writers
California writers has won to the
Greater Los Angeles area writers group
there's one looks like says gloss GLA to
us there's a lot of them all over the
place and and usually every state has at
least one or two writing conferences
where agents come and you can book five
ten-minute appointments for them to take
a look at your work order or US where
some of them will read like the first
the synopsis and tell you whether or not
they feel that your book is a good fit
for them or not and sometimes you know
they've people been very successful in
that so writing conferences for
novelists are also quite good if you do
that and writing groups like the South
Carolina writers I mean they're they
have writers in all different arenas and
they break off into smaller groups
according to you know genres and now
where does someone find these local
writing groups as this like Meetup yeah
meetup is a great one
yeah meetup is a really really good one
in fact there's a gal I know who who
writes and what she does is when she
knows she's gonna be you know going on
vacation or something she has an
agreement with her husband that he takes
care of the kids for one day and she
goes and finds a meet-up at wherever
they're going for a writers group and
she just she's so funny she she's I told
her what she should do
is she should write a short story about
it because she has met so many
interesting people at these meet up once
and it's great because then she has
hosted some of these people from the
different month when they come to her
city they do that
meets up with them and she so she's made
a lot of friends that way too I noticed
with some of these meetups not just even
writing groups but there's a there's a
cost to join it's you know and and I get
why because someone's hosting it maybe
they have material that they're
providing and also I think they want to
know are these people going to be
serious and not just show up so what do
you think is a reasonable cost to join
for a writers group whether it's per
week or per month gosh you know I really
don't know because I the ones that I've
seen it's usually maybe per event mm-hmm
and it depends like the children's
writers group that that that I am going
to be speaking at it's $45 but it
includes my book okay and so my book is
$20 so it's it's you know they and the
rest of the money helps to pay for the
venue
sure and refreshments and and and that
so you know I think you just have to
gauge it a lot of them though I've
noticed they're free to a non Meetup
okay on meetup I've seen some that are
just / are free they don't but it's just
a meeting it's just just a bunch of
writers getting together and just
talking about all the different things
that you know about anything to do with
writing and maybe they discuss you know
a little bit about their you know about
their material and and all that so it's
it's it depends I mean some of them
there are no costs I've seen somewhere
where it doesn't say anything about a
cost but I've also seen some that were
as high as 50 $60 and usually though
it's because there's a speaker and you
have to pay the speaker or you or in
this case for the children book writers
you actually get a copy of the book so
you're getting something in return as
well you're getting a book as well as
being able to hear it hear a workshop
what about the public library do they
offer writing groups I mean do they
organize that or no you know I think
they used to but I just you know I hate
to say it but at least here in
California I've noticed what's very sad
is that libraries are at risk yeah
and not just down here in Southern
California and central California where
I live it's it's like that too they just
can't sponsor those kinds of things
library hours are being cut shorter
notice to do you I mean I remember when
I could go to the library at eight
o'clock at night and make my Xerox
copies if I needed something done or
something and I notice now it now closes
at 5:30 they used to be open all day
Saturday and Sunday I noticed they're
not open on Sunday same with art but
certain other towns are but not city of
LA where we are yeah and I think it just
depends on the area that you're in you
know where I do think they've got a
great system is San Francisco the San
Francisco Public Library System is
beyond par it's just as amazing and they
have speakers that come constantly and
it's free that's wonderful yeah so it's
a you know meetup groups are great if
you live in San Francisco go to check
out the public libraries they do they
and there's a lot of writers who live in
and around that Bay Area that actually
come and speak for free whenever one of
their new books comes out you know
you